so what I want to do here is have a
discussion on all-new all-different
marvel and what I'm hoping is that at
the end of this you'll have a strong
understanding of where to start if
you're looking to get into all-new
all-different marvel as well as what
this means for the future of the Marvel
Universe
so getting into this for those of you
who are well-versed in Marvel Comics
I'll ask you to give me a few minutes so
I can provide a foundation to all the
new fans who aren't familiar with Secret
Wars time runs out and how all of this
came to fruition so the reason behind
all-new all-different marvel rests in
the history of marvel's publications and
where early stories in the 1960s with
spider-man the Fantastic Four the x-men
and the Avengers were all pretty clean
in terms of continuity and crossovers
and 1977 Marvel launched a story titled
what if spider-man joined the Fantastic
Four designed to be a retake on
spider-man issue number one and the fact
of the Fantastic Four turned down his
request to join the team this story
represents the first time that Marvel
had experimented with an alternate
reality while it was not considered to
be in continuity and would allow for the
launch of the what-if series which
focused on out of continuity stories
that provided a different take on
popular events and characters because
the concept was so well received in
January and September of 1981 Marvel
introduced the Days of Future past and
the crooked world stories respectively
both of which depicted alternate
realities that were in continuity with
the crooked world introducing numerical
designations for alternate realities for
the first time while Days of Future past
was the more popular of the two due to
the fact that the story was written in a
time when the x-men were gaining
popularity and because it was a
worst-case scenario for the x-men
themselves the introduction of Marvel's
multiverse spiraled out a series of
stories written by future writers that
would depict multiple dimensions and
alternate universes with varying takes
on characters that we had come to know
and so taking all forms of realities
into account including pocket dimensions
which are miniature universes housed
within larger universes all in all
Marvel had somewhere in excess of 1,000
alternate realities which range from
lengthy series like the Age of
Apocalypse to one-shots like operation
zero tolerance as a result between the
fifty year long publication histories of
their various characters their alternate
reality counterparts and the red cons
that came with all of this beginning as
early as 2011 under Jonathan Hickman
Marvel officially began the goal of
consolidating everything what this means
is that all-new all-different marvel is
not a reboot in the sense that it wipes
the slate clean and starts everything
all over again
instead the
new all-different marvel line represents
a culmination of Hickman and Marvel's
four-year project going through every
title every character every team and
alternate reality and keeping only the
most popular and relevant concepts and
then reshaping them into a more
attractive design that can attract new
readers
so if you're looking to get into the
all-new all-different oral universe but
don't really want to spend a ton of
money on titles that you're unsure about
the best decision here is to go with
all-new all-different marvel 0.1
functioning as a prelude to the contest
of Champions comic which is designed to
be a tie-in to the mobile game point 1
also provides us with a bit of a tour of
the various Marvel titles - The Avengers
and the x-men as well as several other
solo arcs in this book you'll find
previews for the carnage solo series
which returns cletus kasady - as dark
and sadistic routes and feel similar to
the maximum carnage event from 1993 the
Rocket Raccoon and Groot series which is
more of a comedic story agents of shield
which has a feel similar to the TV show
with the same cast members albeit
without the same events all new Inhumans
and daredevil which actually feels
similar to the Netflix series in terms
of its darker ambiance now if you're
someone who jumped in the Marvel with
Secret Wars your initial response to
this title may be a bit confusing
regarding some of the characters and
their lack of reference to the events of
battle world as an example the story
starts us off with the maestro Hulk who
states that this location for contests
of Champions is what's left of battle
world however during our discussion with
the future and perfect tie-in from
Secret Wars which ended with the maestro
trapped in his own mind for the rest of
his life where his appearance here may
seem a little confusing and definitely
raises a few questions because the
answer likely rests in how Secret Wars
ends rather than spoiling the ending of
Secret Wars itself what muffled did was
launched her all new all different line
with an 8 month gap between the end of
Secret Wars and the issues you'll find
here and so while future stories may
jump back and cover the 8 month window
at the moment we can simply take comics
as they are and meet with Secret Wars
once it finishes now like 0.1 Avengers
number zero provides us with a
well-rounded preview of the various
Avengers titles from the perspective of
squadron supreme now unlike 0.1 this
actually requires a bit of knowledge on
things prior to Secret Wars particularly
time runs out however if all you're
looking for is a surface explanation or
you simply just don't care about
squadron supreme the story as it's
written will suffice and that Marvel
states of the group is simply composed
of various heroes from alternate
realities whose homeworld and teams were
too
during the incursions and the eventual
multiversal collapse because of the
nature of the content this will most
likely be a title that will require a
more expansive explanation here on my
channel once we begin breaking down some
of the various stories from week one but
in Avengers issue number zero you'll
find the visions solo series where he is
the only one who seems to remember
everything prior to Secret Wars as well
as Captain Marvel which focuses on Carol
Danvers and more of a universal role
rather than remaining earthbound New
Avengers which centers on the Sun SPOT
Avengers team whose main villain seems
to be Reed Richards from the Ultimate
Universe uncanny Avengers which will
initially focus on Deadpool as part of
the Avengers team carrying out
clandestine missions for Steve Rogers
and The Ultimates which will see the
wildly powerful blue Marvel leading the
multiversal Avengers with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end and I hope you have a good
understanding of where to start and what
we'll do in the next few days is we'll
begin going over the various titles from
week 1 and were to give you guys an idea
of how these new stories relate to the
characters both during this new Marvel
Universe as well as the previous
universe prior to Secret Wars where that
being said that we'll catch you guys
later peace